welcome to this video playing chromos um
somehow i feel like i usually haven't
black against him there's the students
sometimes happens yeah you have people i
know i think i remember he plays that
pretty regularly wow this is what kind
of line is dead i think i actually had
this against him can i what kind of this
is the way it's the weird line night XD
for him I had something with Knight f3 I
think against him also okay let's just
play normal looking awesome check check
yo just playing all that stuff maybe
Nyjah Forza is a problem rufiyaa no he
doesn't do that I mean problem is not
it's not like I'm worse but usually I
like to keep that Bishop there but ok
it's just going to g6 yeah the thing is
can I do something here on the queenside
where there's a scizor pretty much with
orica question i have to do something on
the queenside queen bee five year I
don't know that looks weakening but
Queenie 7 is kind of yeah Queenie seven
looks kind of normal anyway for him
okay i'm going to now is going there
okay hmm so might be five or lets you
force also let's go Nancy form just hope
that I'm not neglecting the defense they
are a little bit too much on the yeah
here we go f5 now certainly
I cannot go f3 maybe this woman try to
force that trade I really need to make
sure that some pieces are traded him but
if i get the night to you for that this
is a fairly safety position yeah I to
you for that that's pretty okay don't
think he has a very serious attack check
here can take on age three on f3 maybe
maybe just all the way back I mean 92 is
a self pin and of course Avenue stupid
stuff that was very unnecessary to allow
that hmm okay ah now there's this very
sloppy game really played this very
uninspired
I think I mean oh I'm really okay after
he went he goes f5 gives me the forska
and so on but 94 quindi one of us is
terrible and now I essentially have to
do that I mean going back to g3 ego ce4
on so i have to take them question is no
it's no question i really have to do the
same problem a problem is that if he
takes on g4 h 2 XG form here's some way
okay the night only three is doing a
really good job here covering d5 and
covering c2 so the rook is not easily
entering yes it's check but well it's
not not au jus deal how to play here I
guess I'm trying to improve my
coordination ah but I don't don't think
it can do that much check yeah okay this
is clear i can put the knight on d4 but
this is not really a huge issue at least
i think that this is the case
I don't mind that Oh am I am I
blundering stuff here d 6 is saying i
also have night f5 or and now night f5 I
guess threatening 97 threatening 1d6
covering d4 naylet that went belly up
for him somehow that's difficult that's
difficult to even feel not use in a
couple of moves
I don't see how we and now i have
ninety-seven just like that and all the
sauce is just now that's easier said
that's if we're okay that's a full
rockland I d subshell let it was
resigned what's already pretty terrible
surprisingly I mean around T I was it
wasn't it wasn't too in good shape at
all yeah that was a really bad idea this
stuck here here I'm okay I just have to
be precise about it with the night not
only for is just very strong covers f2
it cannot be attacked by a porn it make
sure Bishop c5 is difficult so I think I
should be okay yeah shouldn't be worse
so this here and now this this is just
just plain stupid yeah this is what the
computer wants to play and gives this is
about equal now early i really don't
claim to be better or anything but i
cannot i cannot be worse i think with
that good night only form and those two
pieces do a good defensive job black can
try to do this up to here maybe doubling
on their file or so it it should be okay
and now i just didn't see that now i'm
in have to do this and now the engine
wants to keep it on d5 yeah maybe maybe
there's some point to that black can
also still kick by korea by Queen away
but seems to be maybe a bit better but i
think the trade cannot be bad I mean if
we look at this black has black should
be really fine him this oak d1 check 92
where I'm already unsure about that the
computer wants to do this and
keep-keep that night out there forever
that would have helped a lot in the game
and then it gives like this possibly e4
and bring the king of black it's better
here somewhat em engine is on 0.4 hard
to tell how much it is but I'm
definitely definitely worse check 92
king of one and here I'm not so sure
anymore I can now go to see one that's
that's okay and this this is already
feels tricky now i have i have
possibilities here with the night coming
hmm computer is giving me a slight edge
now but this is no slight edge after
this I'm winning yeah it's just it's
just a really over the relatively best
is king of ATM then 96 sent well that's
a disaster really wow surprising how
quickly this is going downhill okay well
thanks for watching